[Music]
bachelor party
let's do it
we got some
we got some surprise guests coming today
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
sit down let's talk it out come here
yeah we're on baby
so yeah yeah get on the mic and put this
on holy hell so so to give a little
background I want to do I was mad I
couldn't be at Norman's bachelor party
at a wedding in La so I want to do a
special podcast bachelor party and Shane
Gillis blows the [ __ ] surprise today
I think we covered it up enough yeah but
I wake up to Gillis texting me and
Norman I I told Caitlin it was a
surprise he forgot
and then he's texting me dude I'm so
sorry I was like it's all right so
hopefully he still shows up but uh
should we start this off wow get some
get some Blown Away get our first guest
out here let's oh my God if you put my
parents out of here Mr and Mrs Norman
ah jeez this is crazy
oh man I can't believe it oh
no
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Jacob fatty how the hell are you yeah
what did she yeah right there there's a
microphone well this is touching you
said 2 30 I thought
ice Matt said come at 2 30. oh really
yeah oh you wanted to build up more
surprises but you guys nailed it you got
the Bud Light the chips the dildo this
is everything we need the fake money the
fake money is gonna that's paying for
dinner later tonight
how the hell are you I'm all right I
just uh I'm all right
I've been on the I was on the phone with
Sonos yelling at them the whole ride up
here because the system in the bar never
works properly you are a human Yelp
right just attacking any product and
everything bad review all right if
something I bought isn't working right I
will get in your ass about it man yeah
this is a combination of the best
bachelor party guests but also a
disgruntled Pi
totally dude this I kind of I kind of
got after it a little bit last night uh
are you hurting I'm not hurting but I
just was on my way in and I was like
[ __ ] I didn't eat anything yet today and
I didn't drink any water so I bought two
waters in this because I was like you
know what I assume we're gonna have a
few pops here today sure
um but chips if you want them
but they they made the problem with the
Sono speaker is it needs to be factory
reset because there's something wrong
with it and the mounts we bought for it
which are the mounts they sell which are
permanent mounts
obstruct the button for you to do the
research ah damn so I was on the phone
with a customer service rep going I
don't understand why would you design it
this way and and then I had to be like I
know you didn't design I'm sorry but
this doesn't make any sense yeah you do
seem like the type that screams of
customer service and then feels really
bad about it I feel terrible about it
yeah yeah I was really just like at one
point in the I'm an [ __ ] at one point
in the call I went she she said
something back to me that I had already
said oh boy and I go remember when I
said
and then I and then I did say I go Miss
I'm sorry you can understand the
frustration this wasn't a cheap thing to
do and it's not working and it hasn't
been working and she's like no I get it
yeah well the airlines have this too
where you want to yell at the lady at
the desk but it's not her fault it's not
her fault man do you want to yell at her
I always say these businesses need to
hire a guy that you can just yell at
like you [ __ ] come guzzling piece of
[ __ ] and he's like I know I know just
hire him you know those those rooms
where you just destroy [ __ ] yes there
should be a dude with like pads on and
you could just [ __ ] wail on them
exactly that's a great idea yeah it'd be
nice a stunt man that's like a side gig
for a stuntman right right yeah there
should be remember that movie hostel
where the people paid all the money to
to kill people oh yeah I never saw it
but I remember it Eli Roth Eli Roth the
great Eli Roth there should be a bad Jew
Bear Jew
and just a regular Jew too that's right
but there should be a fake version of
that there should be a thing where you
can go into a room like you said there's
a guy with a bunch of pads and you can
like hit him with bats and things hurt
him but it will give you the experience
of mauling a man yes you know and it'll
let you get some of that [ __ ] out of
here it's just revealing that we all
have deep-seated anger our ideas just to
beat up a human yeah well who had that
bit about
should be illegal because it'll probably
make you [ __ ] less kids should be
legally mean illegal sorry legal because
the kids getting [ __ ] in the thing
well that those videos already exist you
just you just replay old ones oh this is
gonna get us banned from YouTube just
saying
when this comes out it's a bit it's not
a real no no I know but I still think
YouTube [ __ ] stinks really I didn't
know any gift was here
oh geez is going to be furious by that
comparison uh or as Patrice called him
Eddie uh my favorite Kevin Breton thing
ever ever ever was I was on this podcast
when I go
I go uh
oh we were talking about how Prince
Henry or whatever his name is the Meghan
Markle guy which one man Andrew Andrew
Harry Harry
how they moved to Canada yeah and I go
why would they move to Canada
and uh and Corrine Fisher was on and she
goes she goes well probably because you
know they're pretty lacks like kind of
anything goes up there and Kevin Brennan
goes oh they even let Eddie ift in right
and I started laughing and I go this is
this is the part that's my favorite part
I go
I know you have a problem with Eddie
after he goes now
[Laughter]
it's like indifference the second I was
like there's something truly wrong with
you yeah there's something you're just
you just work this way wow uh it was
very funny that is amazing that's a good
time
being Googled right now relentlessly no
one knows who that is oh boy we love you
honey should we get a second surprise
guest
because this one is a real bachelor
party Vibe hey I don't know how this is
going to go this could be interesting
but uh geez this could be weird uh man
how many people you got in that back
room oh there's this is like [ __ ]
Mori dude yeah people are coming out
[ __ ] you don't know me get a job
let's see if this will and we have
hopefully everyone comes through you
know how Comics are flaky yeah I can't
believe you got this many schedules
aligned I mean we'll see this is
impressive thank you this is I'll feel
very uncomfortable
Mike does not like uh love we'll see if
this works this uh this dildo is very
intimidating it's huge huge is that is
that is that a real dick you think could
shape that it probably yeah the veins
are very realistic the head is uh
perfect this is like it looks like a MAG
light yeah yeah I think it's Antonio
Brown's
you see that thing in the pool yeah he
whipped it out quite a noodle the amino
is going around us he always knew how to
expose the D it's pretty good great
that's great how about Herschel Walker
well he's [ __ ] like his kids he's
running for office and his kids are his
kids are like he beat the [ __ ] out of us
he's a horrible dad then he's
anti-abortion and there's a woman who
came out saying here he he sent me uh he
sent me a get well card and 700 for an
abortion the abortion only cost 5.75.
that's 125 profit right there yeah
and is it Hallmark that's the question
he did the right thing yeah I guess he
could have not said a dime yeah I mean
I'm not saying he did the best thing
yeah sure but he did but then he ran on
it with a platform anti but so it is
hypocritical yeah maybe he had to change
your heart
abortions could really get you out of a
bind that's why I'm a miscarriage fan ah
have you ever done either I've never
paid for two abortion really yeah one I
perform myself no
um but yeah
uh yeah too abortion are we here okay
here we go our our second guest here is
a special guest he's saying well he's
not here a couple minutes oh well
gotta have one lady at this time oh boy
I gotta tell you I don't know who's
showing up either I'm kind of excited I
mean this is the woman of the abortion I
paid for I gotta Pretend This is my
surprise party all right you're still
surprised the abortion woman's not
coming the miscarriage woman on the
other hand is showing up unexpectedly
have you ever gone to an abortion Jam
never me neither I I can't believe I've
never had a pregnancy scare yet well I
always wear condoms ah I mean look I've
had a couple slip-ups in my life but you
know for the most part yeah I was I'm an
accident it terrifies me you're an
accident yeah I wasn't playing I didn't
know that well yeah me too yeah hence
the adoption but right oh I love it
start off a little strong uh-oh it was
the classic we'll give it to Norman
first what is this oh okay
what is that right there that's a money
gun oh [ __ ] funny that's [ __ ] this is
[ __ ]
this is by the way I don't think me
think Matt Peters our producer for going
all out because as usual
I went to a uh
T-Pain was at one of my comedy shows
Once not even as a fan just he just came
to see the show because he likes comedy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how are you can we get Sean around as
well wait around what paper plans it's
our signature drink how you doing Happy
good I missed the uh the events that's
why we told you to come in man the
bachelor party yeah you're here a hell
of a time down there I know I heard I
heard about I'm actually jealous of the
uh you want to sit over here yeah get it
get in frame you're all right you sound
sick I'm just I just got covered it's
fine oh nice
what was your reasoning for not going to
The Bachelor you had some some uh 400
gig you couldn't pass it up pretty much
pretty much I had a you know
Cheers Cheers Cheers
paper plane oh yeah Bodega
catwhiskey.com folks for the people
don't know Patton's officiating the
wedding yeah fun fact yeah yeah I got uh
I've officiated a couple really I mean
uh you know they've none of them have
stayed together so that's why that's why
Mark hired you yeah yeah right and in my
defense all the ones he did were in
blackface
hey I do with a couple requests
that's great though that you're doing
the wedding yeah yeah I mean it's it'll
it you know it is what it is it's fun
I've actually I did um I think everyone
it is what it is got the enthusiasm you
want to hear for your special day
because sometimes no sometimes like I've
done four and sometimes you do them and
they're like just say whatever you want
and you get out there and you say dumb
[ __ ] and it's like it doesn't matter
this is the this is their desire yeah
you know but then sometimes they're like
oh no here's a [ __ ] script I was at
Rachel Feinstein's wedding yeah Tom Papa
I appreciate it yeah dude he crushed it
I mean I was like to the point where I
was like if somebody ever asked me to do
it again I think I might pass because I
I would that would be in my head now
this guy would did so good it was so
yeah but then Colin Quinn went on after
him and zinged him and they start
[ __ ] on each other back and forth
and it's killing oh that's amazing it
was epic yeah that's and that wait was
Colin in the wedding no he just did a
little speech yeah there was just we
that was weird right yeah
wait are you are we gonna do speeches at
yours no
if you want to no like family coming up
and being like I want to read Proverbs I
actually asked my family and they were
like oh we're good we're good really
yeah that's always the worst part of the
wedding yeah I'm gonna say better off
when some the uh when like the you know
the bride's dad is like I have something
to share and everyone yeah here we go
yeah I just wanted to get one I'm proud
of you here's another special guest this
is a dirty Lola hey Netflix is the
principle of Pleasures wow she's gonna
teach us how to perform cunnilingus
properly oh great we all need help I
need a lot of work
good to know I also bought you a present
we got you this
all right all right
um no but I'm modeling good bro gift
giving because these are all tools
you'll need for like happy happy
marriage
yes oh thank you so much about each
thing all right
Wow first we have Lube oh God never
enough
this is by wicked wicked it's Aqua lube
and it's a good all-purpose Lube you
spit is great yeah it's not viscous
enough you need you need Lube it cuts
that on friction less friction better
sex hurt a woman's vagina yes but this
is perfect oh okay
yeah wait just can you use the lube for
cunnilingus is it flavor no ah I got you
flavors right to food
why do you think I'm friends with you
you sandwich shop
so this is flavored lube um this company
makes it with agave and things that are
vulva vagina safe it doesn't have like
the sugars that can cause yeast
infections so it's great and it tastes
actually tastes good okay you know a lot
of these gross there's three different
ones there's watermelon tropical passion
and strawberry kisses hey so you get
that I love it can we put it on can you
put it on a sandwich
wait do funny flavors read it and do
funny flavors you know pepper jack
cheese do funny flavors
Mesquite yeah you're missing the
all-important Christian
there we go oh yeah thank you thank you
very much thank you this is sex oil but
it's vulva safe massage oil because a
lot of massage oils aren't great for the
vaginas like okay inside this you can
use not condom safe just let no oil is
condom safe so
just let you know but perfect for all
the things and you can move what does
that mean that no oil is condensed
condom latex condoms and poly isoprene
which are latex faux latex
um they'll break they get micro tears
that's where you start getting breakages
you can use polyurethane most people
aren't going to hunt those down yeah
right sometimes you find them at Dwayne
Reed sometimes you don't right so yeah
it's a lot of people don't know that and
then they give like full body oil
massages and they put things and then
like how did we have a baby
this is for all the condoms you use
during your marriage sex your
extracurricular marriage sex
before that or not all right thank you
and then
because humans have not developed the
capability to vibrate and most women
need clitoral stimulation oh yes I got a
lovely vibrator from Dame it's called
the kip it's small you can use it in a
lot of different positions it's pretty
and it doesn't look like a vibrator
right away so just in case you leave it
out nobody's gonna be like can I bring
it on a plane yes all right it's
rechargeable so you don't have to worry
about batteries so you can charge on the
plane too oh yeah yeah you can they have
a USB port
and it's quiet so you can use it on the
plane yeah that's the plan everybody
should join the mile high club and then
because all this lube and oil you have
cleanup wipes ah smart so like if you're
being lazy after sex you don't want to
get out of bed these are great also of
all the safe perfect and the last bit
and we'll talk about this during the
class is a blindfold oh blindfolds
actually heightened sensation and
sensitivity so when you blindfold
someone you activate their other senses
so when you're going down
[Laughter]
I dare you to put the blindfold on
before you go down on her I don't know
[Laughter]
blindfold and airpods
I was listening to Rogan let me get back
down there
to my episode I feel like that would be
a moment where your ears become the
steering wheel
yeah yes okay well thank you so much of
course I'm gonna use all this time
yeah yeah
did you say she's out just some bachelor
party humor yeah locker room pacifying
yourself so what what is that so do you
teach cunnilingus yeah I mean you know I
give tips we're gonna talk about Anatomy
that's important hygiene nobody thinks
about hygiene no oh I think no no how
many times have you washed your hands
before you had Oh you mean me yes
yes uh I mean now I wash my hands before
I wash my hands from the post pandemic
right so yeah people keeping that up
because like hands We Touch everything
yeah and then you you're like in the
Heat of the Moment and then you go stick
them inside somebody and you were just
on the subway
it's gross right yeah yeah I I've always
been a bigger fan of hands-free
cunnilingus Am I Wrong it
do but also the other part of that is
talking to your partner like what are
they like yeah it's like you could do
sign language without when you when
you're I really love a game of um do you
like this so you do the thing you give a
lick you give a tug you give a insert
and you know and you're like do you like
this and they can say yes or no more
yeah less when you're learning what I
bring it up first date before the apps
it's on your page lady I don't got a lot
of time
I am a self-proclaimed picky [ __ ] I do
do I'm like hey I like these things I do
that all the time on OkCupid I'm like
you're an Okay Cupid are we gonna [ __ ]
it it's not I didn't even know that was
still going yeah okay please keep please
keep doing that and spread the word on
that
uh because because sometimes women don't
there's like this weird thing now where
men are it's not weird it's just what it
is like sometimes as a guy you're afraid
to initiate a discussion like that yeah
because you want to be appropriate you
want to be respectful yeah but like even
with girls I've dated where they've been
like why didn't we have sex this morning
and I would be like does it seem like
you didn't want to right and I'm not
gonna in this climate sit here and be
like hey what's up what you don't even
like go back I've had lovely gentlemen
slide into my account and just go like
hey what are you looking for and I'm
like oh that's great hanging out or I
also I'm down to hook up if we Vibe I
always do the you want to go on a date
to see if each other is crazy and
somebody's an accident you know you
don't know me either yeah no exactly and
not gonna lie when you said slide in
that count I thought I was like is
account a new word vagina
[Laughter]
my new Jewish book of dirty talk and if
somebody's like no I'm looking to date
like if that's not what you're up to and
I've had people go oh okay I'm good some
people want I'm a divorcee and I've had
dudes go like I'm looking for the one
I'm like not this one that's great you
know but I love I want to know what you
want to do I've had a gentleman I say
whatever dudes man's gentlemen uh say
hey is it okay if I pick a bar near my
house because if we Vibe it's like a
block away are you comfortable if not
I'll pick another place and I was like
that's you're really smart I'm like yeah
that's cool we could do that and then
during the day he's like hey how you
feel it you want to go back to my place
I'm like it's only a block away you know
it's possible it's not gonna win you're
not gonna win every time I always pick
I'm not I'm not just saying this I'm not
justifying anything like I always pick
places near my apartment but not be for
that reason because it it's home field
advantage you're like I want to show
this person a good time and you've the
more comfortable you feel and familiar
you know where it is yeah it's like yeah
but I think if it's if you want to slide
into the like going back to your place
so that they don't feel like this was a
setup right right so we're like hey just
full disclosure I'm I'm sometimes I'm
like I'm lazy I pick places near my
house too I'm like I just don't want to
come all the way deep into Manhattan I
live in Coney Island I'm like no we're
gonna meet halfway we're gonna meet
somewhere else in Brooklyn yeah yeah
yeah that's wow have you I've never met
anybody that lives in Coney Island
was from there he's from there yeah wow
I didn't get the Cyclones that's all
battle and is that the good hot dogs I
feel like you have to be in like the
cunnilingus business to live in Coney
Island right yeah
I mean cunnilingus
how's the economy here in Coney Island
it's good not a robot Coast operator so
cunnilingus directors it's that's where
most of our Cub comes from I thought is
it I thought the Cyclone was just a
giant metaphor for the female orgasm
there's ups there's Downs there's wood
involved
have you ever a guy goes back to your
place do you have all this stuff in the
bedside drawer well my bed has drawers
underneath it so one drawer whole drawer
and my sex stuff drawer okay and then I
also I'm kinky so I have a vase on my
headboard that's just things you can hit
me with oh okay a bouquet of pain
um yeah so like I but I'm also I'm a sex
educator I have a painting of a butt
plug over my couch when you walk in my
house there's a new painting of me over
my bed to Van Gogh right I'm not hiding
who I am I'm very open about who I am
I'm on TV and do different things so
people are like why do you tell people
I'm like it's creepy when people figure
it out on their own
God bless you and they're like
when I want to get back to this bouquet
of pain yeah yeah what's in there do you
mind no crops paddles wow mortenberg
wheel uh wait what a wet wheel it looks
like uh looks like it could be a dental
instrument it's got little spikes on it
you roll it over the skin oh sure sure
there's just all kinds of things you can
hit people with that's sometimes I hit
people with it that's pretty bad bouquet
of pain is also an amazing album title
yeah yeah the deaf tones
sounds like something uh Pinhead would
say in Hellraiser yeah yes yeah I'm I'm
for it I love if when guys I go back and
they already have stuff that I'm like oh
I love an organized man like I'm I'm
into it like I prefer the pain to be
over a long period in the relationship
to build up I like the bouquet to be
emotional yeah get a little a little
both I like all natural no probs like a
Ray Rice
[Laughter]
there you go
I remember when the Ray Rice incident
happened on YouTube there was they were
you would look it up to watch it and
because I just was curious and there
would be ads before and I was like
there's people making money off this
[ __ ] yeah that's insane was Ray Rice the
elevator one yeah yeah yeah okay that
hurt on a lot of levels
[Laughter]
yeah
any any cunnilingus tips like while
you're here because I think we could all
we could all learn something yeah what
do we do
hate to see a guy go down like that
so many things
oh whoa Matt can we zoom in on this when
we have the all right all right the
charts
so this is what the clitoris looks like
on the inside
what yeah so the clitoris isn't just a
little nub on the outside it's actually
like the Tardis bigger on the inside
it's got lungs it's got yeah it's got
legs and Bulbs so this is the bit that
would be outside it look
oh look whoa learning AIDS so that's the
part you see but this is all inside so
this is behind the pubic Mound so it's
also a system of veins and nerves just
everything running and it runs all
around the like along the thighs up the
spine it's the whole thing oh boy when
you're down there massaging the thighs
is a great thing because you're
stimulating the inner clitoris applying
pressure to the pubic Mound or like
pressing your face in really hard yeah
like not hard where they're like oh that
hurts but applying pressure you're
actually stimulating the inner clitoris
when you put your fingers inside because
you say hands-free the G-Spot is just
the button to the inner clitoris so you
are doing an A B combo when you have
your tongue on the outside and your
fingers
yes do you get special moves finish
finisher
I saw a thing I saw a uh I saw a thing
Nina Hartley did once because she's like
the master of all amazing yeah yeah
she's great but I saw a thing when she
was like when she would like go down a
girl and I started doing it and it
worked which would take like the sides
of the vagina and like kind of like put
pressed like you know like kind of press
them inwards oh yeah and and then the
video the girl went crazy and then when
I tried it it worked yeah I was like I I
was like I don't even know what the [ __ ]
I'm doing we're applying the pressure to
that because of that thing behind yeah
what we see yeah yeah yeah because it's
amazing when women get aroused it grows
it engorges same fat and juicy and it's
ready so it's the more pressure you
apply or when you when dudes are always
like why do girls like wands those big
and it's because it has a big head and
you can apply pressure and you're
pressing it against your body it has a
lot of surface area so you're getting
like a whole you're not just hitting
this you're getting
got it fat and juicy kind of like the
sandwiches the Joey roses Lower East
Side guys give it a give it a look down
to Joey Rose
get the sloppy roast beef
Michael Michael the beef curtains
Michael J legitimately on several
occasions now has tried to convince me
to do a sandwich called the titty
sandwich that's duck breast chicken
breasts and turkey breast I love you I'm
just like Mike it's a sandwich shop that
like sometimes families come in I can't
have a thing like a kitty sandwich
it's just it has no ring to it it just
doesn't it just got a good name for the
first meal that's true you know yeah
yeah yeah
anyway sorry I thought that story be
better
soon can I have another one of these
things
the pressing of the lips are you
pressing of the lips
we're a terrible host paper we also have
you know everybody's labias different
sizes like the Libya Majora is the
outside of the vocal what you see uh
sorry some people's labia is you know
smaller some is larger but like and some
people just like balls some people like
the Olivia sucked played with this is a
conversation again because like not
everybody likes their balls played with
not everybody wants their labia played
with you do you do I follow the vote for
the no because you're like not me play
with my balls and labia I'm in all of it
thanks Joe that was awesome
do it again
lamb chops
oh
oh my gosh that that's
okay so what do we do with the [ __ ]
because sometimes I go too hard on it
yeah you know what you tell it'll never
amount to anything
you're never gonna make it nothing like
your brother yeah
and also file your nails like if you're
putting your hands you don't hang nails
or just sharp nails or or get some black
nitrile gloves oh they're not just for
serial killers they're really sexy and
they and they just keep it where you if
you're not gonna go get a manicure you
can just put them on it's like a scuba
suit for a scuba dive smooth entry it
cuts down on any Nicks or things because
you feel everything so they feel even
when you think your fingers are okay
they're like oh my God yeah it could be
really sharp so using Lube because
that's going to cut down on the friction
and the more you use it helps you pass
over it in an easier way okay um and you
can slowly apply pressure same thing
with your tongue like right you want to
start out with lighter licks and then a
prime plush pressure and you don't you
can do it with just like sticking your
tongue out like really hard but also
using the flat of your tongue yeah like
you're eating ice cream got it all right
less like you're trying to dig a hole
and more like you're like eating ice
cream like okay strokes and you can give
more concentrated when you like tighten
your tongue oh God it's the speed speed
yeah speed Applause I mean it's going
with the motion of the person you're
with so like where are you in it how are
they like if they're like more then you
can add more speed you can add more
pressure
being able to switch Direction yeah also
though
kind of pay attention because sometimes
you're doing great and you go I'm gonna
do this now and we're like but why oh
yeah the other thing right you're like
you get an idea and we're like nope you
were fine right okay because a lot of
times as a guy I think hey it's going
well I'll double down right and that's
the opposite right because it wasn't
needed yeah it wasn't you were doing
great you could you can check in I've
had somebody give me like do the finger
things and go like yeah well they're
going and I'm like yeah you're good or
oh
we talk about that beforehand all right
um these are like the sexy conversations
I mean also as a couple you can make up
your own language like when she pulls
her hair what does that mean if she
pulls your ears what does that mean oh
yeah that's like a picture yes yeah yeah
hey oh hell yeah there you go there it
is thank you thank you buddy hey keep
them coming you too is crushing it here
he's using a cunnilingus in Staten
Island a lot of people don't know that
yeah this is really good what is what's
in this this is the bodega cat paper
plane so it's the traditional specs of a
paper plane but made with our own we
might be trying to dig a cat rise so
it's aperol Amaro no nino lemon juice
and rye whiskey I've never heard of a
paper plane I well let me bring it back
today we are all on a paper plane yes
Cheers Cheers Cheers on this thing
to drink this like I eat [ __ ] let me
dip my nose in it real quick I have some
things so you can practice yeah oh bring
it on God I'm so afraid
[Music]
pass them take one pass them around oh
my god wow that's a big Puss look at
that oh yeah that's a gorgeous this is
what melania's [ __ ] looks like after
Donald eats it you're the birthday boy
all right
no it's for you guys yeah let me see so
what do we do I want you to start like
teasing right it's the beginning give it
but no not no that's the you're at the
anus go to the top I mean that's where
he starts I always go away
oh no but don't flip it around if you
were eating [ __ ] if you were in
position what would you do you'd bring
the [ __ ] to your face don't bite it
don't bite it yeah but yeah now lick but
stick your tongue out more than your
chin yes okay sure yeah yeah light licks
yeah think about all right this is
actually pretty hot now that you were
eating soft serve like give it that like
big it's melting I'll be honest I I
pictured the Scruff of either of your
beers hitting my uh nuts and it made me
I gotta be honest I feel like that'd be
nice on a lady like yeah
what about this I got a whole patch for
you babe I'm not I'm not against it I'm
not against it I'm gonna eat your [ __ ]
after this
don't be afraid to like really get your
face in there right sure
to get you to eat my [ __ ] [ __ ]
finally I'm allergic it took 12 years
you don't have to just focus on the [ __ ]
you can also go for the vaginal dirty
Lily's gonna leave and we're gonna be
horny we're gonna [ __ ] each other yeah
you got that we do have Melons I'm just
saying yeah you know I have [ __ ] a
melon have you oh yeah did you finish
inside it yes and I put it back in the
fridge oh no no I'm joking
like for later but you also can lick
around the vaginal opening now this is
where doing a tight tongue formation
like a stiff tongue and going inside yes
because that shallow pellet penetration
we love that [ __ ] like right at the
opening you hear that oh really that
have you not right when you first put
your dick inside somebody there's always
that like yes I hope yeah yeah well I
get a lot of you in yet
so like that that kind of sensation is
really lovely so if you're if you are
going hands-free is it weird if I'm the
one that makes that sound now no because
it feels great it feels great and
moaning into it because vibration yeah
that is a way you can create sensation
like a yodel you could run bits on it
not yodel like a deep like um
[Music]
this is for the ladies listening
do the stern thing what produce do women
practice on for uh for blow jobs usually
either bananas or cucumbers I'm allergic
to bananas so I usually bring cucumbers
but also too a banana seems too um
fragile right it's a harder skin outside
no you don't take this you don't take
this kid
what about the curve how do you feel
about a curvy dick I mean aren't they
all curved no sometimes they're straight
we got a real sometimes they curve left
sometimes they like a hard curve
sometimes they put the curves come on
Ryan
mine looks right back at me
that's a magic dick right there that's
good you're gonna do that you're gonna
hit that spot yeah looks right back at
me you can also get into those anterior
furnaces aka the a-spot it's the spot
between your cervix there's a gap like
as you're going to the cervix
yeah that's pretty cool so many things
okay how how long is uh long enough
and be honest I don't you know like this
here is that enough oh I every penis has
a purpose
that's a good foundation yeah I'm not
like some smaller penises are great for
anal I wear them like that the penis
made for anal because you're like I'm
not gonna mind that let's do it hey this
is great or just also everybody's shape
differently positioning like moving
putting the hips up can change how where
you're hitting how deep not everybody
wants like deep because the back of your
vagina is the cervix that [ __ ] hurts
some people like it but nobody wants you
to keep punching it it's all the time
especially if you're not warmed up yet
so like shallower more mid-range can be
great it's different for everyone some
people there are size queens and they
know what they like but yeah I've had a
myriad okay like everybody has their
gifts they have the things they know how
to do well sure it's not the size of the
boat it's how you drive it right if you
understand how to use it yeah size
becomes moot yes I tell myself this
every day yeah I've also like and when
you ask how long for yeah if you are in
no shade like sometimes people just
don't last a very long time and if so
that's as a way to elongate because the
more you warm up
towards orgasm sometimes you might get
an orgasm during oral it's great because
you probably might get one to roll in
after during penetration but like the
more you can have things happening
before penetration penetrations like
it's not even the whole Sunday it's like
this is part this is a part of the
dessert but like everything else is
happening the making out the going down
the fingers the toys doing things
changing positions all of that is like
all of that is sex it's all a partner
sex so it's it really comes down to like
how much they need sometimes you'll get
be like okay you're in like yeah I don't
want more I want I want this I want dick
I don't know if you've ever been pulled
up it's time to get in the game oh yeah
I love the Pull-Ups
so sometimes they'll let you know when
it's do women uh are they more likely to
come not during sex would you say like
normally is it fingers or cunnilingus
it's like definitely penetration alone
is kind of a rare thing for most women
not all there are some women who come
during penetration and that's really
easy for them but it's just how we're
put together we need clitoral
stimulation and where the G-Spot is or
the access the access hatch to the inner
clitoris isn't always placed in a way
that through penetration you're gonna
get it so like that's why I love A vibe
because like while you're penetrating if
somebody can also be using a vibrator
you're more likely to get an orgasm in
Sex and there's different kinds of
orgasms like not all of them are like
the big fireworks penetrated penetrative
orgasms tend to be like these weird
rolling that's where you get like the
convulsing where you're like oh my God
you're having an exercise yes sometimes
you come it's like an art house indie
film you're just yeah yeah yeah
it's okay two stars yeah yeah great yeah
good yeah all right I think I got I
think I got a real Peter Dinklage
situation like it's smaller but there's
a lot of talent and a big head a huge
they make dildos like that so yeah
really oh yeah also there's like uh yeah
you said it best there's I feel like
women have there's such a there's 15
different types of orgasm a woman can
have whereas a guy is basically just
like right yeah okay there's done done
here just my jacket Magic's more of a
wee man it's small but it'll go anywhere
it'll do anything it'll take a hit and
keep going
yeah and Stevo's seen it
don't be afraid to do things out of book
think there's like the order like oral
doesn't have to be before okay like out
of order yeah like I so finger the ass
then put the fingers for whatever neat
like for me I like making out I like
penetration I don't come that way but
then after I like oral and then a toy
usually I'm like get things out of the
bag I'm instructing and I'm like here
here's the dildo here's the thing I want
and then like my partners do you like to
sit on a face on a face I will yeah
that's fine I will say if you want that
you have to be very encouraging because
especially if it's a bigger girl they're
worried they're gonna kill you
some people now some people don't care
and we're they're like whatever he
Smothers sure he's mothers
um but you know so it's like a thing
they make cleaning chairs for that it's
like a chair with straps and it has a
gap in the middle and you would lay
under you flat in under and they sit on
your face sounds like it'll be really
good for my neck because yeah but it
creates a different positioning for
giving oral so if you don't want to be
on your belly you want to be on your
back and they're not too comfortable
sitting on face like that they make
cheaper ones that you can like buy that
you can put together okay sometimes I'll
bang the lady and then I'll I don't want
to bust yet so I'll pull out and go down
on her yeah she doesn't like that is it
because what was because they she wasn't
ready yeah she's like wow no that's
weird or and some people have weirdness
about because your dick was there these
were conversations like I have that like
how do you feel about
kissing me after I've gone down right
I'm fine I'm fine with everything but
um those are things that you talk
because then you don't want to have that
like no why would you do that yeah okay
we don't talk but uh this is all good
advice
all right that's some great weather some
hot ass sexing like hey oh I got a
couple questions so women do get horny
yes interested yes I've seen it some of
us more than others some some of us need
a lot more brain Activation so like
Chinese ladies with the garbage bags
full of cans you think they're horned up
somebody they must be why do you think
they're in bars selling cigarettes for
eight dollars bro trying to get trying
to get something dollars what is 1998 do
you think you can get a cigarettes for
eight to eight no that's that's what
that's their that's the hustle though
that's what they do they sell eight
dollars
for like 10 bucks or whatever like
because it's like buying for me it's
cheaper yeah they get it from North
Carolina in New York Bodega what what do
cigarettes go for like twice
yeah yeah yeah yeah no they're probably
in Manhattan are they 16. I quit about a
year ago they're around 16. yeah
Manhattan sometimes they try to get you
if it's like a good brand there's like
twenty dollars yeah
John Hills or whatever though yeah yeah
also sometimes well they knocked my
Gloria Swanson
well also they have porn those Chinese
ladies oh really I mean back then they
said yeah full of DVD Stacks out no if
you buy cigarettes I always bought them
from that lady that would come in
[Music]
she gets off she'll watch Modern Family
and hit the hit the vibe I mean hey Ed
O'Neill
he's a daddy you can do it would you
[ __ ] at O'Neill
who's your number one I don't know I
like I'm I'm digging older men when that
picture Steve Carell with the beard came
out I was like
okay
but with the beard it was like Hey Daddy
like this
I get it my favorite I'm not getting my
favorite mature like mature women I love
milk a hot chick like what's mature like
what's your age honestly like I get mad
when they're like 35 right give me a
[ __ ] break like but if it's a chick
still like does it for me like that's so
[ __ ] amazing you like The Walker The
Walker oh okay well a walker depends
listen
wow Herschel where's the Goddamn Rim
shot
the older women is still like they're
like doing legs over the head oh yeah
older men are like I just got this one
for you I date a lot of older men and
I'm like what okay yeah what window are
we into nothing Silver Fox yes Bluetooth
is a game changer for these old are you
taking it no I mean I don't need now I'm
still in my 30s but I have friends who
are younger than us who take it oh
really yeah yeah oh yeah I have just to
see how and it works it's like it's
actually yeah dude I did it once did a I
did a Cialis once like it was just it
was kind of crazy like it felt unnatural
but I get it like it's just like uh it's
nice though because it works when you
need it like I guess that was true but
it felt like you're just hard yeah
you're praying it goes away after four
hours Cialis is like you can access it
when you want to use it but I felt it
was like once it was up it was like
please go away now don't you when I did
it didn't have that effect on me like I
I had sex on it I'd never done a blue
chat hours after I did it took it
I took it because I was I was really
tired and this girl wanted to hang out
but it didn't we had sex once and I was
like done I was like what just nothing
yeah
oh you wanna she wants to get coffee I
should take some blue cheese
you know no no you never know once she
gets caffeinated the panties come off
wow we were in Vegas and she was like
let's hang out and party all day
tomorrow and I was like uh I was
supposed to go home that day you changed
a flight for it I was living in L.A and
I was I was driving but
I was just like well my hotel's up so I
don't know you know it was one of those
things you're like kind of like things
she's like come stay with me come on I'm
gonna get a bunch of blow we're gonna
party yeah
no I did do it okay
listen I don't know I probably shouldn't
have gone down I'm like I'm gonna die
are either like highly pornographic and
amazing or like shitty rom-com
I love it so much you're like sometimes
I was banging this chick on a private
plane or I spent three weeks with this
girl and then she left me
I spent three weeks paying for this girl
she
[ __ ] I told her I loved her I wrote a
song and then she was gone the sandwich
shop
that [ __ ] a good [ __ ] sandwiches no
no comic
I'm a comic too I don't just share
no no it's it used to be we got
grandfathered in when you could still
make money doing it yeah yeah
podcasting's a [ __ ] too though
that you can't you can't believe the
money you make podcast yeah it's
interesting it's nuts it's wild look at
the studio they'd move these guys yeah
especially if you know Sal
yeah especially if you're a podcasting
mates already hyper famous yeah it helps
there's a fly on this vagina right here
hey you know some women are into that
yeah it lands right on the clitoris and
starts doing that thing what do you
think they're doing they're doing this
with their hands
do you feel equipped yes I actually feel
better actually yeah can I can I say
something yeah and I understand why it's
slanted in this direction uh-oh but I
noticed every gift is for her it's not
but there's you know he can also get a
massage flavored lube is great on a dick
okay all right fair enough and I get to
[ __ ] the cantaloupe but I noticed there
wasn't anything like like uh like helmet
jelly or something like that
you could use that one fair enough you
don't want to mix here's the thing
penises actually have skin they don't
really have mucous membranes so less
[ __ ] affects you than like the whole
once you get past the outer vulva like
it's all mucous membranes your pH gets
thrown off if you do the wrong thing if
you drink something go down you know
it's got it wrong Lube so you want to be
careful so that you can keep having the
sex but all of these things can work
with a penis I also think to but I also
think too that and I swear to God I'm
not saying this for points with the
feminine gender but I do think that when
you live in a society that is so slanted
and sexist for so long there does need
to be the the the the focus on sexual
pleasure is needs to be swung the other
way because it's it was not explored to
the extent for women that it was but
also you can use a vibrator on your ball
right really yeah listen you could come
look you could stick that in your ass
that big dildo right there that's true
anything goes Buddy yeah
you could suck that dildo
but the vibrator that smells terrible
you could just use it run it up and down
your the shaft of your [ __ ] and you can
have an orgasm that way with this no
with the vibrator oh okay on your balls
that's a good point they make they make
now they're catching on The Vibes
yeah okay but you can use that for the
same thing so everything in this bag is
interchangeable this is a dirty Lola you
rule yeah yeah good that was awesome
thanks thank you so much for coming in
this is amazing
I saw it I predicted it yeah
are you single at the moment
um I'm polyamorous and I I practice solo
poly so I have a partner in California
and I'm just dating here can you do a
social weekend plug or something yeah so
I'm on Instagram and Twitter at dirty
Lola and my website is dirtylola.com
check her out you're great and I do
these glasses so I'm in New York are
those breast implants I'm sorry I got
yeah it's a little squeeze if you want
uh all right out of all of us who would
you [ __ ] first
the Hat then the glass hey but you also
have a name yeah it's a beard it's the
daddy I am I am freshly single so oh
wait what wait what you know this no no
oh my [ __ ] saying this on a podcast
uh what yeah it's all good we're good
it's all good we're all good it's it's a
good one it's a good thing yeah
oh I'm sorry no that's right it's a good
thing is he takes a giant gulp not a
cocktail there's no way there's no way
to talk about it without everyone sort
of like having the same reaction but
yeah we like amicably ended things a
while but we called you here what's a
while back
May
wow we I still we still hang out we're
still like very cool we're close but
like Sean there's just a guy that always
in our defense Sean's a guy that always
acts like everything's perfect yeah
wrong yeah
yeah okay no it's we're it's
everything's good we're still cool we're
still super cool we're here buddy eight
and a half years and now single so I'm
like learning the ropes again oh my god
well this is perfect I do your dating
class if you need help with your dating
profile yeah you know what Sean [ __ ] it
yeah there you go I'm good
that's the first time you've eaten fruit
oh if it wasn't on top of shredded pork
yeah
oh you're great thank you thank you
thank you so much
thank you
we're gonna look up your website please
do oh yeah thank you for the bag of
course enjoy all right I'm gonna send
you a video of her [ __ ]
don't tease me
real quick one more I'm sure I'm sure
I'm sure it's very just like
yeah there's a lot of that I can't
believe it's going to be a video of
Emilio giving her seven minutes folks
listen
hahaha
seven minutes is more than I give her oh
Hey listen hey oh all right oh that's
Insider can I yeah oh wait is this all
secret what like who your lady is no no
is it I'm really asking this I'm not
being the smartest is it tough that you
both are doing comedy stuff like is that
does that make it tough well it's good
and bad it's ups and downs uh because
the bad the good is like we can talk
comedy we can right we I don't have to
be like oh that's comedy she doesn't
know about that so she gets all the
comedy stuff so that's nice now the bad
is at what point do you
step in don't step in help don't open I
I I would I I I said I think it's not
just because it you want anyone
especially she's you've been doing it
what you've been doing a while she's
only been doing a little bit like a
little bit a couple years she's gonna be
way more it's gonna benefit her
immensely to do it on her own I agree I
agree but it's it looks bad but how
about this and I'm like I don't know
about that think about think about the
people we know who've had who've helped
significant others that ultimately did
not help them good points I think
keeping it separate it's great you know
there's a great example that is
um uh Sarah Silverman and um camel no no
no Rory Albanese Rory oh right you know
like they have their own stuff
Rory is much more established in the the
sort of writing side of things yeah
Sarah is a bona fide celebrity they both
have their own thing but the point is is
like they they did their own stuff and
they got their own stuff and you don't
see them T they don't have a podcast
together and all this [ __ ] right right I
mean
Joe and Sarah yeah list and told them I
guess they've been doing it probably oh
oh they've been running they've been
running I knew a great example it's very
very separated you know like it's I
think it's I think it's good and and
she's cool dude I think she gets that
she's a good egg yeah I'm a lucky guy
yeah yeah yeah I think she definitely
understands but yeah every now and then
I think the struggle when you're new is
so rough you know you don't know what's
gonna happen is this am I gonna get
anything am I going the right direction
you know you know the whole [ __ ] idea
the the greatest generation was I think
was the one that coined the phrase I
just don't want my kids to have to
struggle like I did but that ruined an
entire generation that ruined the
Boomers because the struggle is what
made them the greatest Generation right
yes yes so I look at it as like yeah it
is [ __ ] hard it's I'm gonna go Tom
Hanks in [ __ ] A League of Their Own
it's supposed to be hard the harder is
what makes it great but like that's the
point it was easy if you start [ __ ]
knocking out the hard yeah then they
just pop to the tool whatever their
generation that was like even [ __ ]
guys like JD Salinger were in the war
like Ted Williams Brooks
Elvis yeah Elvis Jonathan Winters yeah
U.S marine I know but this is can you
imagine can you imagine the front lines
being this oh dude we got this dude are
you kidding me we could do it level I
mean that guy the left look at yeah
maybe beard you but they're us four
biggest Target in the room no no no no
dude the penta [ __ ] rage Just Between
The Rose and I is enough to form a
[ __ ] infantry yeah
we would be on like like a predator
Squad where they'd be like that we sent
Sean a joke to the Jungle if we're like
yeah we're like we don't know what
you're doing yeah you'd be on customer
service with the AR-15 rep these jam all
the time what the [ __ ] man I feel like
if we're still Team Six you're the
sniper okay you're back uh you're
demolitions you're running around I'm
probably Intel I'm hot I'm the guy you
know just opening their eyes on the wall
oh yeah and Joe you're the breacher
you're the guy who just runs in there
loud [ __ ] aggressively yeah
where'd he go God damn it yeah there's
always cigars you know yeah but I'll
tell you this I'll tell you this this is
the beautiful in my opinion for whatever
it's worth the beautiful medium that you
can have with your partner which is you
can say to her
you will always be supported you will
always have a safety net I am here for
you one thousand percent and at through
every emotional step of this insane
Journey you're going to flip it through
it and that can be completely separate
from but you but go out there and earn
your own stuff yeah those are two
different things I agree you know right
and that's that's a beautiful thing you
can offer somebody I think so but
sometimes a lady might see like you're
not helping me as a dig
there's also ways you can help that
aren't like let me call this club Booker
yeah that was nice when you let her sell
merch at your show yeah
you can sit down and like have come and
be like hey maybe look you know advice
is always helpful yeah and also like
there are there are definitely ways
where you could step in and be like hey
this is an unfair situation I'll balance
that out there's lots of ways to help
Mark as you can see here yeah there you
go
I think I think the kind of support that
you can give her is so much more
valuable than yeah oh I'm gonna bring
you on the road with me to open or
something right right I mean my ex was a
is a does musical comedy stuff but like
that was the greatest part was like we
both understood the road very different
was where it was like hey I'll see you I
won't see you for two weeks it's nice
when they get yeah yeah girlfriend's
like what you're going out again it's
dinner time you're like that's when I go
to work yeah yeah but we can't go to a
movie
yeah yeah dinner is a sign of stability
I think in a relationship for sure a lot
of people it is but you're also you guys
God damn right it is oh
all of us
and uh and I've been I've been arguing
this a lot lately with comics
we're all at a place in our careers
where you don't have to go you don't you
can be there for dinner at this point
you don't have to be out every night
doing spots we all don't have to be
running around doing four sets on a
Tuesday anymore it's stupid there's a
new crew of people there's a new class
of people they're coming to their turn
let them have their turn we're all going
on the road we're all doing our thing we
all have carte blanche to a certain
extent we all have places that we can
drop in on if we want to
you we can regulate the amount of sets
at this point yes it gets to a point
where it becomes this obsessive
compulsive uh fraternity code yeah do
anything it's hard to shut off I agree
with you I think you're 100 right but
Mark and I've talked about this a lot is
that Mark and I were so used to doing
those five sets a night that I'm just
starting to shut it off yeah I found it
incredibly easy to shut off I don't who
the [ __ ] wants to be sitting there doing
that like I did I did eight spots on
Saturday it just sounds miserable but no
but it worked it was one of those
situations where just the balance and
the timing worked out beautiful amazing
but it was one that was like I know now
like oh this is a lightning in a bottle
situation yeah yeah like it doesn't
normally do but but I also like seller
jumping around room to room it was it
was uh Brooklyn comedy club New York
comedy club stand seller just like
perfect not having a run but it was one
of those situations where you're like
this is great but this is also too much
yeah like five spots is better I think
but also at the same time like did I say
this joke it's sitting
excuse me I uh
I was out with I was out with Paul
Italia last night I don't understand and
we you know we we have the bar together
but we went out we were talking and I
said yeah I go I just was like Hey man
you're not going to see me for a little
while at the club like and he was like
why and I go because I go because it's
gotten to a point where it's just
becoming about the cash grab like I have
my new hour I'm going on the road and
I'm doing it I don't have a ton of new
stuff I want to work on because I'm
perfecting the hour on the road I don't
want to break the hour up into pieces in
New York and the stuff that I'm doing
when I get on your stage or the seller
whatever is just stuff to fill 15
minutes I don't get there's no when I
need to work again I'll be back you know
what I mean that's kind of it you don't
feel like you lose it over like a week
of taking off no I think I think the the
with the amount that we're all talking
at all times and performing in our own
ways at all times between the podcast
and yeah and radio and and but that's
different ever it is but I think this
concept that you that you that you're
going to somehow lose your mojo
you know what I mean because because you
take five or six days off from stand up
before you go on your next Road gig is
so insane it's it's as to me that's as
absurd as Austin Powers losing his Mojo
you know what I mean like it's crazy
it's like guys we know you know what
you're doing but I guess here's the
thing too though like I do like that
though I do like for me I'm like oh I
like my four or five spots a night
though I do too if you like it that's
fine yeah but I I just remember a time I
remember a time when I was the guy
desperately trying to get the four or
five spots yeah yeah and I remember
uh somebody's saying to I won't say who
it was because I don't want to blow up
any big spot but I remember somebody
saying to me going yeah you know why you
can't get four spots a night because
these [ __ ] guys have made it part of
their income that is not what this is
meant for no I agree with that you're
supposed to this is not meant for guys
that have been doing it for 20 odd years
to take up all the spots everything it's
not about income for me for me the road
is the income for me the city spots are
the uh like let me just make sure this
[ __ ] isn't hacked let me be on a line
yeah but when you're working on me let
me fine tune it sure like I'm always
working on stuff though that's the thing
yeah I I agree with what Mark just said
we're always [ __ ] trying to hone [ __ ]
we're always trying to be like hey does
this work it is hard it gets harder to
break up the hour as you yeah
you don't find when you get to the home
stretch like I'm gonna do my new hour
for New York for the festival and then
I'll probably shoot it or I will so
you're not going to be a mark sweating
no I'll be yeah no I'm doing it and then
flying down the next day actually uh
what are you coming in early to the city
when it's to come Wednesday and stay a
couple extra nights hey make a make a
meal on Tuesday I can't say why but I I
can't I that's when the show is but but
my point is I'll try to come Tuesday
come Tuesday I booked Wednesday
I gotta book it actually I gotta book
the flights you got a hotel stavi baby
and I uh I think Ari's getting a big
house be prepared to drop [ __ ] three
grand because they because the city
because Airlines know what they're doing
when they're like oh you're trying to go
to New Orleans in November or any time
of the year five grand flights up here I
just spent I just spent 2200 on a a
round-trip flight to election in
Kentucky oh dude Kentucky will just
[ __ ] rape you
my skank Fest flight for Vegas was like
800
800. let's get to Vegas it'll be like 16
each way it cares and it was [ __ ]
like do you feel like the city is the
deal with the airport you know I had to
truncate the the stay because the long
the full stay was like 1300 bucks what
that airport has [ __ ] slot machines
that Airport's making money yeah right
but um
I hear you I hear you about it's not
about the I I hear you I I think I find
that this is my opinion I find that in
the home stretch of the hour
real quick I just got to point this out
real quick uh I was I was here doing a
podcast another podcast they're like
come stop in I'm like yeah I'll go on
for a second I got I got I got therapy
what time it was supposed to be at three
we pushed it to four okay hey folks this
episode is sponsored by better help look
Adidas dropped Kanye so to Balenciaga
better help should pick up Kanye he
needs it if life came with a user manual
things would be easy for everyone but it
isn't so when it's not working for you
it's normal to feel stuck navigating a
career change a new relationship or
beginning a parent becoming a parent can
make you feel uncertain therapists are
trained to help you learn productive
coping skills which makes therapy the
closest thing you'll get to a user
manual for you we all go to therapy we
all go to the same guy love him love him
it's a game changer you got me in I'm
hooked he knows me too well I know we
were talking the other day about a toxic
woman and he goes uh you're not done
with her I was like yes I am because I
know how you are you love it I'm like I
was like [ __ ] you Alan man he's good oh
yeah he is good better help us online
there without his video phone and chat
therapy sessions you can choose to to
not see anyone on camera if that makes
you feel better tell them how to do it
fatty as the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched 3
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch back to a
new therapist anytime it couldn't be
simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com drunk
that's better
help.com slash drunk
hey folks when you want a smooth high
that you know is made right here in the
U.S of a look no further an ounce of
Hope based out of Memphis Tennessee uh
ounce of Hope is your One-Stop shop for
Delta eight Delta 9 and CBD Edibles oils
and more I use this stuff every night
literally to go to sleep I love it it's
not too high you don't want to go into
some edible coma where you can't see
straight you don't know when you're
gonna die and you're panicking anytime
the phone rings this stuff is just the
right amount it's just perfect it helps
me sleep better harnessing the power of
aquaponics
ounce of Hope is the farm to table brand
for getting high aquaponics combines
fish and plant farming so all the
nutrients released by The Fish make an
extremely healthy plan oh you're getting
high thanks to fish [ __ ] visit
ounceofhope.com and use
drunk for 20 off your first order that's
o u n c e o f h o p e.com with promo
code drunk and start saving on the best
Delta 8 and Delta 9 products here it is
get on it
all right
just cancel it you're gonna you're gonna
limit this is gonna be like pro
wrestling you're gonna limp out we're
gonna tag someone in yeah all right all
right no no I love that I love the beard
you yeah it keeps coming to being like
oh are you low get in there sorry Joe
sorry
I I think my point is just like what I
don't know maybe we're maybe we just all
operate differently but I just feel like
you get to the point where you're like
this new hour is really strong and
here's where it needs to be and that's
it and it's like I a part of my brain
just starts to turn off where I go when
I go oh that could be a bit we'll see I
don't know I don't know what the next
thing's gonna be like I'll jot down a
note but I don't feel like I have to run
out this week and do four I tell you I
disagree with this a little bit I
totally hear what you're saying but I
think
the city sets are 15 minutes so it's
kind of like okay this [ __ ] can stand on
in an hour on the road for the people
that are paying to see me yes but in the
city they're not paying to see me
they're just paying to see a comedy so
it's that plus can it hold its own in 15
minutes following a guy at the cellar
like Daniel Simonson who's gonna
annihilate because his [ __ ] is great
yeah with Greer Barnes who's going to
annihilate because he's a murderer can
it hold its own following those dudes
that's what that's what Ari said I agree
now he argues I'm let's see about this
with Ari
who gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
Works no your act does work for the for
the my people in an hour can it work
this is why a lot of comics lose their
fastball is because they're talking like
you're talking no I disagree you lose
your fastball because in the downtime
when you're building I already did that
when I was building the hour I gotta
keep doing it that's stupid well what
about new material new material will
come when I'm ready to put this hour
down and start working on a new hour
again that's what I'm saying it's
turning off the switch of I have to keep
writing constantly at all times because
if I don't I'm a shark not moving and
I'll die yes I don't agree with that I
already did what you're saying in
building the hour in doing the 15-minute
sets there becomes this obsessive thing
where it's like if I don't keep doing
that though if I don't keep running
these 15-minute sets of the hour that's
already crushing then I'm somehow not a
real comic I'm somehow gonna lose this
we didn't say that
I'm saying like I'm just saying like in
general I think people start to feel
like because this is what you do I think
people operate differently like I mean
like sure Kyle Kinane who is I I think
one of the best out there love him I
think he's [ __ ] brilliant but he's a
guy like you like he like he likes to
just like do his hour he likes to get
out there sure he but he's also so like
just naturally [ __ ] hysterical you
are right but I mean like Kyle is a guy
who like I'm not gonna say it's
confidence I'm just gonna say it's like
it's who he is but he doesn't mean this
is what I'm saying Russ and Eve said to
me once this is what I think we're
saying two different things Russ Ben Eve
said to me once
uh he goes he goes we I was like doing
like the late show or something and he
was kind of giving me like a hard time
about doing the light show and I go
whatever and I went up on The Late Show
and I came off stage and he goes how'd
it go and I go oh I killed and he goes
oh yeah really the jokes still work oh
and it's like yeah that's that's what
I'm saying I'm saying you do what Sam
what you just said yeah to build the
hour once it's built enjoy you take it
out you get to now just do this show
your approach is healthier as a human
I'm just saying as a comic I go two days
without a set and I feel really yeah
that's why I say there's a subconscious
thing working that says if I don't keep
doing it I'm somehow letting myself down
as a comment
it's nice to have an outlet I I get
nutty if I stay at home for a day and a
half I want to get out there yeah after
I do a set I'm like I feel better about
working it out yeah it's like I enjoy it
so you don't but you don't think they're
there that's an addictive in some way
I'm sure it is but it's a healthy
addiction and you also don't well is it
wow
I don't think it's unhealthy like I
think like I actually better than
drinking
but sometimes I'm like oh [ __ ] I really
want to work on this bit and I know the
only way to do it is to go out and do a
[ __ ] that's that's the difference
for me like yes I do have those run the
hours I do have those nights where it's
like this [ __ ] addictive and yeah but
sometimes I'll do that where I'm like
I'm gonna do 15 minutes I already know
works I think but I love that I think
comedians
I think a lot of comedians uh are like
obsessive AAA attendees after a while
where a guy goes I got 35 years I go to
six meetings a day it's like bro if you
can't navigate it after 35 years without
going to six meetings a day you got
another crutch in your life now you can
say that that crutch is healthier than
the previous crutch which is booze but
for Christ's sakes man you you get you
got other [ __ ] you need to work on
that's right okay but that's you like
for me it's like I personally just like
actually love
even when I hate it I still love it yeah
even the bad like last night I had a
[ __ ] you were there I had a [ __ ]
just a roller coaster at the at the Vu
but it was like I was I walked out of
there like [ __ ] but then was
still like ah [ __ ] there's three things
I could do yes yes and like I truly
loved that [ __ ] even when it beats me up
like I still like I it it it I it's the
one place I feel kind of normal that's
how I feel I need them too
I don't think at all I'm saying you and
Canadian are that same way all washing
each other but like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
well I've had this conversation I know
you're not being offensive I just prefer
I like getting up I I get off the road
and I'm like [ __ ] I want to go to The
Comedy Cellar yes I want to do a set I
wanna I wanna see how these jokes hold
up because sometimes I go on the road
and it's the people that are coming to
see me and a joke does a little too well
and then I come back and I'm like it's
not that good I need that I need that
humility that I get that I guess uh
we're just we're we're saying the same
thing in Reverse I'm saying like to me
you don't I don't take it on the road
for the full hour until the road the
hour on the road doesn't count until
it's already perfected in sections in
the city that's fair so then then I'm on
the road and then all of a sudden it's
like boom are you trying to know when
you're when you're building
yeah but they're [ __ ] off shots I don't
you know I think it's something new out
of that I do okay well then it's worth
doing I do I do but my point is is
right we got to change the subject
no keep it going guys
you sit here and I'll sit there oh no
that's the David tellsy ah nothing says
you're late then balloons on the floor
what did I miss a countdown
[Laughter]
I love the location Midtown right in the
uh finger on the pulse
how are you yeah you're here man yeah we
got you a nice coffee oh hey well thanks
yeah you know um there's no better way
than to leave it out
awesome you know I was invited so turn
it up a notch
my show so I saw you last night did you
know about this or yeah well Sam and I
have been talking okay behind your back
and I know that's your style but
um
you and I were talking and I said where
are you going to go on the honeymoon you
said I have no idea yes and I came up
with a few ideas do you mind please
please be prepared uh I don't know if
you know this I know you follow the news
yeah but um
Shanghai is open oh oh there you go no
more lockdown so that's I didn't it
doesn't seem to hit that was just I get
to know it idea ready
right okay now your lady is also a comic
yes there's no better place than yep
Jamestown New York the comedy Museum
thank you you know if your relationship
is half as successful as the legendary
Lucio Ball and Desi Arnez yeah we're
thinking more Rich Boston
well now I'd just like to promote my
dates and leave
[Laughter]
it up I'm going to DC and uh you know we
all know it's fun down there and uh it's
a driving gig which is always fun I love
a driving gig you do now should we bring
David on this this pow wow we're having
or is this yeah sure as I said he will
100 disagree with what I'm saying but I
well here's the best part it's great to
see Joe yeah buddy he takes a lot of
days off which we just discussed yeah I
was trying to recount it if you're here
who's watching the store as we say
[Laughter]
I was saying and everybody disagrees
with me and I I presume you will too or
assume you will too but I was saying I
don't understand after you hit a certain
stage in your comedy career the because
Mark was talking about like a tough
thing in a relationship is if you're not
there for dinner because you got to go
out and do spots and I said but you're
at a stage where you can be there for
dinner because you don't need to be out
doing five sets on a Tuesday night
anymore you go on the road like this
obsessive thing that Comics do in New
York where it's like I have to be out
every night all night the entire time
doing sets I don't understand it after
all but we enjoy it yeah we all disagree
I don't want to go to dinner yeah I get
I want to eat chicken wings
this is a wild idea uh-oh maybe cut back
on the thing you want to do for the sake
of the other person my point is is
they're married yeah yeah there's you
know what I mean like this Con like like
the thing the another thing Comics
another thing Comics do I have to work
New Year's Eve if you're not a comic if
you don't work New Year's Eve I'm like I
disagree with that no take off on New
Year's Eve and go hang out with your
loved ones never a good show it's a
nightmare I just I just don't that's
good there have been some good there
have been some I've done a couple I
don't understand I I just I I mean
you're also more I think maybe
go ahead please don't uh don't kill me
here but you're more well adjusted than
most Comics even though you are a DeRosa
yeah whoa bro he gets it out in other
ways
I'm not I'm not claiming to be more
well-adjusted or anything I'm saying
like I said I argued with Ari about this
the other because because it's like out
of one side of his mouth it's like the
scene and it's great you got to do it
you got to do it the other side is it's
not what it used to be and it's
different I go exactly it's different
it's time to move on yeah do you can
drop in and do your sets you can go on
the road do your sets there's a new crew
they're more woke they're more this
they're more that we can all go and do
these shows and piss and moan that oh
the whole crowd was Instagram fans of so
what what why it's like I hear you don't
need to do it it's still a gig but I'm
saying you have real friends who are
outside of Comedy you own a business you
run a bar but isn't the real fairly
whole answer here for Joe to marry your
lady
yeah it seems I hate to come in as a
Ukrainian Matchmaker but you're always
ready to settle down you still crave the
bright lights yeah you want to get out
there 12 people in Williamsburg I'm
there a rooftop yeah what time but Joe
all you craves is to look at patterns on
Fabrics sitting at home did you say
something honey I was watching a TV
what do you Dave I was playing one of my
15 video game devices
honestly what do you think of of that
take or whatever what you said yeah yeah
I don't know you get older and you're
supposed to eventually you know
disconnect and have a real life but for
uh you know it's kind of difficult to do
it and I know yeah you made you made a
choice a while ago before actually the
pandemic you're like you know what is
this all about and I respect it but for
a guy like him especially he's like uh
you know it's uh what's my call it it's
like a
you know that's his uh reason to being
and I understand it because like you
know you feel like you have to get out
there to get better and that's where it
is and uh in New York that's kind of why
we all live here as well because we have
that option if we lived in a uh I'm just
gonna throw it out again this Jamestown
New York like if you live up there there
probably wouldn't be as many would you
places to go out but I would say that he
should compromise with her but she's
also a comic so she must understand she
gets it so the other the other side of
it the other side of it one thing we
left out was that Sam and I were going
back and forth with is I said because
Sam said you want to know that the hour
Works no matter what you want to be able
to break it up into 50-minute chunks and
go up after anybody wherever you're at
and make a kill and I said but you
already did that when you were building
the hour when you get out like my new
hour is almost done and it's like okay
so when you get out you feel like this
is pretty much ready I feel like I don't
have to go out and do as many sets in
the city because I'm not building an
hour anymore when it's time to build
again I'll do more sets sure sounds like
you don't enjoy stand up I love stand up
I don't enjoy
uh uh the the organic
repetition of it exactly a bombing yeah
yeah well like I said like like when I
was talking to Paul last night I said
I'm gonna step back for a little while
from the club and he said why I said
because my new hour is ready I don't
really want to break it up into chunks
anymore and I said I'm if I'm coming
into your club I'm just coming in to
fill 15 minutes all right and this is
where I wish that's when I would work
out yeah couldn't you have a new idea
but I don't play with don't you want to
make twenty dollars
[Laughter]
I think it's just a matter of either
whether you want to take a break from
writing or not right you know well I
think we should focus on the amazing
fact that Dave is up before five it's
all pretty good I think that uh I didn't
know this was going to be this kind of a
life coaching
you know you have a real business so you
know you have something you have like uh
I respect that more than a lot of things
where it's like you know you said you
were going to do something you have to
follow through you did it right and you
know uh I'm hoping it's a success we all
are so but you know the whole idea of
like is comedy it for everything for
everybody for all time no it it
definitely has to be more chapters but
what drives me thank you that's very
nice for you to say I really appreciate
it well that'll be time to promote your
place Joy Rose's
what drives me nuts is like I'll talk to
certain people and they'll go hey so I
heard you open up and they start talking
like as if like I don't do stand up
anymore I'm like no no I still do stand
up I just do both I just have to collect
Paul dude
but people will be like but I don't
understand like why how could you do
stand up if you're not constantly doing
stand-up and I'm like because because I
I feel like you can do two things sure
why is this any different than if you
had a TV show or something you know what
I mean but I hear you but TV people are
saying wait where they go from gig to
Gig to Gig they never take a Mark I
think Mark Patton and I are like you
know we looked at a towel and Colin
Quinn when we when we started here and
we're like this is how you do it I I I
agree I agree with Collins approach
spots before 8 15 only and then going
home but Dave and Colin are always at
the selling we're just like oh we should
always be going up absolutely but it's
what you get out of it I feel like a lot
of times I'll leave there shaking my
head going like that well that was I
didn't get anything new out of that I
didn't you know I I didn't do anything
um particularly what I wanted to do and
it just became this kind of like you
said like just kind of fill in the time
you know but uh you know I just know him
and I know these guys here and that's
like you know it's who they are and they
have to do it they just there's really
no choice to it they have to do it
there's no choice sure you know so that
it's really tough to like you know
that's what they always say about comedy
you know you lose friends and all that
kind of stuff because you just you know
it's this world you know you give
everything to that world Dave none of us
are asking Superman not to fly yeah
but you know I mean nobody writes at the
clip that you write it like like and I
mean that is a compliment you're right
you guys are all very strong writers and
they and they definitely not get these
guys the uh no they're they're great
right I'm saying like you you write it a
clip where I'm like it's it's truly
incredible like right because you always
had that I don't know if you still do
this but you you always used to have
that little book yes and your dick
story for when I'm dead so I don't
really like talking about myself but uh
since this is more of a like I guess
this is a faux basement correct this
isn't I that's when you guys set this up
at a 16th floor but yeah it's supposed
to be Bari I get it so here this is your
hangout this is your secret garden this
is what you guys get to say this they
got to get out of here and do a set
there's a 6 p.m but you like hanging but
you you like hanging at a comedy club
right
[Music]
I don't as much anymore because I feel
like it's such a new crew of people that
I don't really that's just well how do
you think I feel I'm like 100 years
older than you so it's like but the
point of it is that yeah that's it's in
you now and that that's what you feel
like you can hang and be you know it's
like it's like if we were all uh
veterans we'd be at the VFW you know
what I'm saying like you just you would
go there you know and I played there and
since we're just a bunch of cowards I
guess all we have is this comedy I feel
like I feel like I hear you I hear you I
feel like and this is the last thing
I'll say I'll shut up I Feel Like Comics
I Feel Like Comics get into the uh Jack
Nicholson in A Few Good Men mentality
where it's like I've done 17 doors and I
eat breakfast every day 100 yards from
30 men that when it's like
you can there's another way to do this
no I'm Jack Nicholson and one flow of
the Cuckoo's Nest I'm I'm working to
brain dead that's my plan that's all I'm
just I don't wanna I don't want to be
I'm Jack Nicholson Robert Duvall what's
that one game Apocalypse Now going we're
gonna surface the bombs come off I I
can't get out I'm Christopher walking in
a deer hunter there's characters in a
million war movies As Good As It Gets
that's right living with OCD yeah I feel
more like Helen Hunt a wet t-shirt I've
got a boy I need to care for
that boys you're inside let gay guys
live in my sparrow
get in there these Creeds are in my
spare room but when I say well adjusted
I mean you have a business you have
friends who aren't in comedy or you're
you're normal more it's not it's not but
I so first of all I'm not claiming
anymore adjusted and second of all I
feel like normal in the comedy world is
a bad term let's let's move on hold on
we're gonna hear the sound of it oh I'm
sorry
is that on purpose that the the uh the
flip phone Dave on purpose I mean if
you're not you don't want you not have
an iPhone I I have multiple phones and
phone lines and
um you know I don't want to brag or
anything I have an account at Best Buy
um the mic in here is can people hear me
because I'm not getting the laughs I
think
we're laughing out there
I have to ask you this why did you guys
pick this location that's what I want to
know uh the producer came to us and said
we'll we'll design it and we said sure
and because it's it believed from last
time too it did because you were very
close to the fabric uh in part of New
York where the fabric where you can buy
buttons and Yarns and whatnot I thought
this has a crafting element to it are
you guys crafting while you're here this
is the new thread business I think you
think so yeah they're shooting the
sequel to uncut gems a block
a podcast correct I think you're really
good on them I enjoy stand up too there
you go
I don't think sad
I love podcasting well there you go I
don't really it's just what do you think
you like do you think before podcast
like what did you do before podcasting
would you gather with a group of friends
maybe at a diner and talk to them about
the events of the day or we would yeah
we would all sit around and go we should
be recording
[Music]
I'm pretending you have a crowd here
[Laughter]
Shoes stand up still what
I didn't think you were gonna go that
way I aren't you as far as take the
money off the table as as so you give up
you would give up hundreds of dollars a
year as a stand-up
yeah that's that's pretty brave what
about all the comparing peanut butter to
Honey how are we gonna live without that
that's not my problem I don't listen to
this [ __ ] all right I just talk on it
but the uh no I I as far as what the
thing in and of itself is nothing would
ever beat stand up because it's
immediate yeah you know uh but as far as
convenience and money go podcasting is
far sure easier and you know right yeah
which is why so many Comics went that
route because you can do it from home
it's good money isn't it [ __ ] funny
that it's still named after something
that no longer exists iPods iPods oh
yeah
podcast yeah it was it was birthed at a
time we had a downloaded thing onto a
thing that wasn't your phone yeah
podcast oh yeah
yeah and using one with a glove that's
like a condom
now what about Tick Tock Joe do you
think you might put a toe into this this
world Tick Tock the The Frigid Waters of
tick tocks which you put a foot in do
you have a tick tock account where you
push it I really don't know what it is I
thought it was a character Dave is not
Dave is a tick tock get in here I've
been with somebody's Butlers like yeah
he's not running his social media at all
we were in a car once remember and I
asked him like Dave how the hell did you
post a picture of us while you're
driving he goes oh that's not that's not
me yeah no I don't I don't like it yeah
I don't I don't get how you guys do this
consistently I really do feel like and
this is a successful like everybody
talks about your podcast so I'm glad to
be on it but like how like people I know
a lot of people who've been doing them
for years now with not many followers
now and they just enjoy I guess the
experience of talking but like I I have
trouble doing it like for me it's just
not my thing I look at it as it's like
to me it's like a radio gig like yes
morning radio is kind of like what I
what I know more than than this it's
enjoyable but it's certainly a
commitment and but if you can make it
make sense in your life and and it's
fruitful I think it's a fun thing to do
and that's what I missed about the
morning radio is like we're having a
little bit of conversation and then hey
we got to talk about the weather or hey
there's a pile up on a highway yeah you
got to get on top of that there's no
immediacy to this if you want every
seven minutes one of you should say the
weather and time yeah mattress and lanes
and a lovable character comes in and
talks about you know some bake sales you
know what's [ __ ] great you know what
I missed I don't miss but about morning
radio you ever have the time where you
get where the guys like the producers
like Hey listen they love it when you
get in there and just take over yeah oh
so I get to go in there and do their
[ __ ] job for 45 minutes
they go hey man she loves it when you
[ __ ] on her go in there and give her and
then you go in you'll be like ah nice
hats stupid or whatever and then you
leave and you're like give it a chance
come on
she was really mean to me she seemed to
not like me at home what advice was that
that never works I got hired to host
some Halloween show for AOL it was like
my big gig that was like an open micro
at the time paid five thousand dollars
the most money I'd ever seen in my life
and they said be edgy we saw at the
comedy seller we like your edgy spin I
was like all right whatever so I'm hope
I'm judging a costume contest and I'm
trying to be edgy that's what they
wanted it's a big production cameras
lights big audience and I go uh all
right here comes Catwoman cat one called
a hot lady with the whip and the whole
leather and then she leaves and I go
give it up for the African queen and the
African queen is walking on and Cat
one's walking off and I go watch that
whip around the African the [ __ ]
cameras wilted the lights went out I got
fired immediately but they always say go
edgy and they never made it no no no
early pandemic a dude from New Orleans
reached out to me was like Hey we're
doing doing this day-long Marathon to
raise money for healthcare workers in
New Orleans we got Norman and we got
Theo two other comics from Louisiana yep
um there's gonna be the three you guys
which Theo Theo Von oh okay yeah yeah I
didn't know if you went from The Cosby
Show yeah that was yes and it was like I
got three guys you got you got to share
the hosting dude he's gonna be great and
I log on to the zoom thing you're like
all right so Mark and Theo dropped out
it's just you and it was a full [ __ ]
day of just me being like why I I agreed
all day all day how was that terrible oh
did you shoot me there money there was
no money it was a fundraiser oh wow that
was early pandemic so I was like I gotta
do this right right but yeah that's I
want to tell can I tell them real quick
my favorite one of my favorites please
uh this was years ago this is like at my
mom's rehab where they have balloons in
the fall kick them around a little bit
get moving out go ahead uh this was
years ago Dave and I used to live in
Hell's Kitchen yes and we used to go out
and have a few uh I remember that
apartment that was a bird's apartment
right apartment yeah yeah we used to go
out and have a few drinks together there
one night you said uh you go Joe let's
go over to the Hustler Club on the West
Side Highway yeah and have a few drinks
and we went in that's not cheap it was
not actually we went in right before
closed right before last call we got
last call is he like warm or they're
like Dave it was empty okay we got two
Budweisers and two shots of whiskey it
was 58. yeah right
in what year uh probably 10 years ago a
stripper came up to us she goes Dave
goes
so where's like the party after this
like where like where's what's the after
party and she goes oh my God there's a
great place we should go to
Horatio Sands hangs out there a lot and
Dave goes oh really
Horatio
like that and she just walked away
the New York strip scene is not what it
used to be it's more than 10 years ago
by the way
that's great this is why we need you now
more than ever
your archive of half drunk stories
half drunk
I remember when you were on tour this
was I don't like this kind of job all
right I had a good story change it to
another comic yeah it was the Lewis
Black oh Mitch edberg Hedberg you and
Bill Cosby and y'all kiddo y'all came to
New Orleans I remember during your set
this was like I mean I was it was uh at
the Orpheum during your set you had a
bottle of Jagermeister and you you were
you would do shots every few bits and
you kept looking off stage and going are
you coming out or not
and then you just talk back to the audit
do some more bits and go are you are you
[ __ ] coming out or not and then
finally the person came out and it was
Doug Stan yes oh
and everybody's like oh
cool and then y'all do a shot together
and someone goes give Doug Mike and you
were like yup then you gave him the mic
and Doug's just like hey man I'm just
here as a fan these are three of the
best comics in the country right now
it's awesome I'm just I'm with you guys
I'm looking forward to being here and he
had the mic back to you and you go could
have been YouTube okay
what the [ __ ] was that that's what
you're gonna do in a theater get the
[ __ ] off stage
then we woke up on the Levee
was a dream guest on this podcast
hilarious he's been here
oh man oh Santa's awesome yeah I love
that guy you know he he'll work any town
except New York is really the one that
like it's really tough to get him into
you know really
out here was great I I asked him so many
times ago can you come to the cell he
doesn't like to go and like you know
he's a guy who you know you talk about a
guy who's able to take off oh yeah he
was really I guess you could say the
pace car of it where he was really good
about like you know I I'm in I'm in
where he lives in Arizona you know his
little town and he does other stuff he's
got all stuff going there and then he'll
he'll go out on the road like like like
really like Road dog like bar shows in a
van you know for like weeks and then
he'll come back and I'll do write a book
or something
he's called me a little late and going
like how much would it cost me to get
you to play my backyard right now that's
a weird
asking yeah I just feel like watching
some stand up I want to see it in my
backyard so yeah yeah I love the but
yeah Doug is a guy who definitely can
balance the two sell out like salmon
drying plant and yeah
that was the greatest show Santa wasn't
allowed at the at the festival
you were there all right were you there
it's not a great story but he got into a
screaming match with the booker of the
festival in the lobby of the hotel got
pretty ugly and he said [ __ ] it I'm
doing I guess he called it the no Fest
or you know it's called spite no it's
called Justice fight just besides I was
I was in the with the next year when he
did just for spite yeah the following
year right you saw the bird of the idea
in a car wash okay he held it was there
I was like a Nancy show with Patrice
yeah and Otto and George God Rest both
their souls and uh I was I was backstage
and Doug was hanging out in in the
downstairs of that theater and I
couldn't see what they were saying I
just saw that him and Bruce Hill were
talking to each other yeah it's getting
more elevated yeah and then all of a
sudden Brazil which goes you know what
you don't get to wear this and rip the
laminate off his neck and goes get out
of here and literally Shuffle dug to the
door and shoved him out wow he
delaminated
I actually remember you're laminate your
I remember
put it on the table I know he's wearing
this you're out yeah it was embarrassing
put your poutine
put the snakes back in the peanut butter
so we didn't put your mime if I do
t-shirt on that no no he did the floor
he rented out the car wash across the
street yes and he said I'm running I'm
getting 10 kegs and I remember word
spread all that day and I remember you
[ __ ] guys former manager I'm not
gonna say his name but his name's
and
are you thinking about going I'm like
I'm definitely going he's like oh she's
just gonna burn your career to the
ground right now and I was like [ __ ] you
and I went and everyone was there
already everybody including him
eventually
no one [ __ ] cares it just shows her
enough like even Bruce Lee I love Bruce
Hill even Bruce didn't care he was like
he was there oh yes I'm gonna let you
hang out here do you say something so
crazy because I need to shove you out
the door
Doug is such a legend and like I mean
he's we got to get him on here
I mean we love Doug he's a great he's a
great guy he's my favorite he's what I
consider a real comic so he always was
the guy I would call and go like do you
think this is hack what do you think of
this and you know he would like uh you
know we'd go back and forth with it but
uh yeah he definitely is there's nobody
like him so best episode best episode of
Louie oh that's his episode oh that's
great that's the best episode of The
Green Room was you and Stan the other
day oh that was a long time
[Laughter]
Dave goes hey did you hear about the
hurricane tomorrow and I go no what and
he goes they're going to shoot a couple
episodes of The Green Room down here to
dry things
that was a great one because performing
too that was one where they lost power
and you could hear the generator like I
love that that made me feel like you
know like this is real like gritty stuff
yeah I remember that I remember the
generator
good job
listen if anybody knows jokes it's that
guy yes we uh yeah remember those shows
everything in the city was was blackout
Ben's Pizzeria was charging 60 bucks for
a pie wow it was so [ __ ] dodging they
were gouging yeah I remember Uber calls
it up Denver yeah I saw Stanhope at
Caroline's yeah it was great and then
you showed up and he goes Dave is that
you and you go I heard a white Voice
come out of Caroline's I had to see who
it was a [ __ ] place
how dare you do that in front of your
Lincoln tall bartender
sorry he freed the slaves at the um yeah
at the Mitch Hedberg Memorial
yeah he died
that's been a long time now you had the
line of the night though you what you
said yeah go on I know I know you hate
this but let's have some candles let us
just adore you somebody put some
cellophane on that cantaloupe I know
right because uh he goes a lot of people
ask me why I never told Mitch to stop
doing drugs but let's be honest that
would be like a stripper telling a
hooker to wear less makeup
you know Mitch
how was he wow he's the guy who would
have crushed it on Twitter because his
jokes are so so like amazing but I don't
know if he would enjoy the podcast
because he was definitely another guy
very very introver very selfless you
know uh reflect even regardless with
substance he was always like it was
always hard to get like a combo going
with him and like you know the one thing
that I did love about Mitch was that for
a long time in comedy people carried
around a notebook before the iPad and
everything like that sure but like he
actually wrote stuff in it and it was
good stuff instead of other people like
yeah I got my camera up I want to see
you know I got my Emojis on on the you
know stickers but like his no I remember
him opening one time and it was like I
was like whoa look at this it's like a
da Vinci Code stuff there's like you
know like a perpetual motion machine
design you know yeah like little like
definitely thing so I was like he really
always wrote he was definitely a writer
comic like he would write and then he
would perform it out there and he would
like you know sometimes he would go on
stage when he was I guess bored or just
felt like you know hey I just want to
see you know I'm going to read some
stuff out of nobody and that became like
a style to something yeah people oh yeah
I mean he's the most guy he's the guy
that like I think he can all agree you
can hear the Hedberg in a lot of people
oh yeah yeah he's like oh yeah that
sounds like Hedberg nowadays just say
ask if they're queefing yeah yeah he's a
big he was a big influence I think right
on Dimitri Martin
and Dimitri is one of those guys he
would show up with like a ledger at
shows and I remember saying to him one
time ago Dimitri what is all this and he
like opened it and showed me and he was
like he was like and he had these
symbols next to these jokes he was like
this symbol means it worked perfectly
this symbol means it needs a little bit
of work this simple smoking doesn't work
at all this and I was like wow that's
really like a committed yikes like you
know like a squid game correct triangle
versus Square
you mean the squid game is that still
irrelevant
so back to this AOL gig yes do you have
a contact
was that one of the most fun times
you've had do you think I think that
that was a stressful uh Tour all the way
through because Mitch was really deep in
his you know and this is like already
I've said it before but he's very deep
and we were all really worried about him
he had a leg thing and you know he was
uh but I think he was added on the last
guy of the tour so you know like Lewis
is uh he's like a he's a road monster I
mean like this guy like has been on the
road consistently for decades now you
know like almost like before you guys
were born he was out there you know like
he's never stopped and Hedberg was also
like you know he's a power headliner and
you know I was a headliner so it was the
whole thing of like who clothes you know
like we wanted met we wanted Hedberg to
close in Minneapolis that was his
hometown you know but like for some
reason that didn't happen or there was
like a lot of those little things that I
think got to Mitch but the but the whole
point of it was is just that like he
wasn't at the top of his game but he
still was great and uh I'm glad that you
know I got a chance to do that with
those guys but I think now like the way
people turn now like you know to use
like the A-list comics of where they
bring a bunch of guys out you've been on
these bigger Arena tours and stuff like
that yeah I'm sure that's a way more fun
experience now where they just kind of
like I felt like even back then it was
like one of these things where like you
know Comedy Central had a hand in it or
somebody had a hand in it and they were
trying to like you know like it has to
be you do this much time either right
whereas now it's more free form and you
get to like do it like that so I think
that the comics now have more control
over the bigger venue shows that we did
back then it was like okay I'm doing my
time you know blah blah blah you know
and I think uh you know I I don't know I
think that Hedberg would have crushed it
in today's world of like theater you
know I think he wasn't he was definitely
feel comfortable in the theater in the
theater situation whereas I feel more
comfortable in a club how about you guys
what do you do well you know what's fun
is like we did we both did fully loaded
and uh it's so fun Bert Kreischer has
these giant Arena gigs these ballparks
or whatnot race car NASCAR track we did
and it's so nice as a guy like me
because I get to party and I don't have
to sell it he sells it yeah you get to
show up in this you know eight thousand
people what are you doing though like 15
15 20. he's a great guy Bert he really
is like all the way through I was really
excited to be on his tour I did three
dates with him and I got to my bucket
list places Dayton Ohio
um Rochester New York
Rochester Jamestown no no no James
that's [ __ ] that's sacred ground yeah
well he he books those because he
doesn't want to hurt our markets oh
really I thought it was for him like
almost like you know these are small
outdoor venues and I'm just kind of
getting it going but I was like he he's
class all the way he's a fun guy yeah
he's up for anything I said to him do
you mind if I do this he's like he
doesn't care at all and the fact that he
brought like uh I would say that it was
a really good sampling you know I'm
talking about like a like a buffet of
Comedy like different styles different
people and uh you know his fans they
were really giving they really were up
for it you know he he's just like you
know rock and roll comic you know oh
he's got a great heart and he's good to
everybody so so I'm not saying that just
because like you know what I it's like I
really it's great it's great that Bert's
out there you know it's like the future
for you guys Jimmy Buffett
I want you to like do what you do it's
not there's no yeah no filter or
anything like that out there you know no
he's never uh put any rules no crowd
work no we have a lot of love for Brooke
Chrysler here man yeah yeah bird is
definitely um I would say that he's
definitely guide to look up to in terms
of like what you guys want to end up
doing where it's like you know he he
first of all he's 57. oh yeah yeah great
storytellers that's like a skill that I
don't have Joe what do you think well
after that story Dave
I constantly prove it over and over yeah
no I I I I love bird man for the same
reason like it's uh it's just he's he
did it himself there are guys that are
just like balls of energy you know yeah
that's just kind of that's kind of what
he is like he gets off he gets out like
the crowd like he meets the crowd you
know it's a party yeah you know it's not
like he does he's phone I've only ever
done the one the weekend we did with him
Ari O'Neill Wise Guys Wise Guys uh red
is easy uh with the storytelling show
but Bert there's only four shows but
like every [ __ ] night where you know
the shirt comes off which that's a thing
like I've heard people disagree with
from like you kind of have to see it
live yeah because you see people like
actually like dude I remember cream
their [ __ ] pants
no way finally oh yeah [ __ ] blue lives
matter
you say it man we're not going what's
the problem officer
come on dude oh yes
I'm already ready all the things that
man hold on let me move across the room
yeah he's ready yes wait a minute I
asked for a black woman what the hell oh
no I mean oh yes
here we go wow how much did you pay for
this [ __ ] this guy's gorgeous yeah yeah
this is the worst thing a cop is that
this is how I think I
look at that [ __ ] wow
Joe he's like you but he made better
choices look at this guy yeah there's no
sandwich shop here sometimes yeah oh
yeah thank you any any phone
this reminds me of a time one time with
the tough time time
[Music]
wow
that's the way here we go where are you
from Middle Earth
folks
all right there we go wow you guys
missed his uh therapy
canceled already meanwhile I'll pay the
late fee meanwhile Norman and her ladies
Norman's lady and her friends are at the
go-kart course
come on girls this is too hot this is
too much I've been turned and it's
shaking what's happening what's the
beard you you guys should fight
oh you're getting it buddy you're
getting it
there you go oh here we go the audition
has started oh I love this coffee table
oh man
yeah wow
yeah this is you get it he's like it
wasn't great but whatever dude it's a
gig he's working on new material
yeah
all right I've never thought defund the
police before but now I get it
[Music]
yeah looking good this is awesome all
right I knew I signed that NDA for a
reason
you're not gonna get this on Rogan
oh yeah it's a one-man party in here
yeah here we are just a couple of kids
book editors enjoying a successful we
can't play the song
oh it doesn't work I tried it it doesn't
work try it it's supposed to shoot
should I put it in your mouth oh yeah
let's put some money in there yeah there
you go sir oh [ __ ] is that funny money
yeah here's a five really uh here's a
five make a man out of them wait is that
actually fake yes I thought you just had
80 grand stack wow
no wait wait wait I started telling you
this earlier I went to a circle with
T-Pain he taught me how to do this all
right he said what you do is you grab
[Music]
[Music]
he's the guy getting married so do you
have any advice for him yeah please
you're the one who gets married yes yeah
should we give him all the secrets of
the game I think he should so you're
gonna start working with us
are you guys hiring
you're equally as ripped
four yeah I know my height how many days
a week do you work out give me give me
three five
don't tell him he'll tell you don't do
it less
thanks I just got a text from a from a
fellow comedian yeah
this guy's an artist he took him right
down to podcasts there we go were you in
the movie Bros
it didn't do very well oh wait we really
that was at the screening in
Provincetown
[Music]
where do you think they should go on
their honeymoon because you know they
kind of uh there's a couple of great
ideas but I say Rascals in New Jersey I
think it's closed yeah what's a good
honeymoon destination he's from
Switzerland uh as a professional
homewrecker have you uh Hawaii really
good okay no he doesn't got that kind of
money I mean like maybe Staten Island
[Laughter]
[Music]
would you like a drink because they have
some real drinks over here you want a
drink I don't drink but oh smart can you
make him uh give him a B12 shot or
something hey
started
yeah use this one do you want do you
want a cocktail as well uh sure can we
get Shane a a paper plan here yeah thank
you sir that was great
this is a mess it's getting ugly this is
ugly and I'm not feeling great really
why is that oh I just I'm gonna wire
money to your account down you know what
was what was with the nasty comment when
I walked in
who made a nasty comment he was trying I
don't get it that was all love dude
oh give it to us dude it's nice time to
finally show up thank you again for
coming by finally show up
[Music]
thanks Rudy get a test I don't know Rudy
do you want to plug your dates
he's going to be a hilarious
I'll be in a duplex cross town in about
an hour and a half and then I'm heading
up study yeah very handsome guy Twitter
[Music]